that other shocking story at a Florida
or the FBI now says it assumes that
Friday's deadly attack at Naval Air
Station Pensacola was terrorism the
gunman a 21 year old from Saudi Arabia
reportedly posted anti-american tweets
before the rampage the bodies of the
three u.s. sailors who were killed
arrived at Dover Air Force Base last
night while their grieving families wait
for answers our lead national
correspondent David Beck now has been in
Pensacola all weekend looking for
answers himself David good morning what
more do we know now about the shooter
according to social media posts that
we've read which appear to have been
written by the gunman he hated the
United States of America CBS News has
confirmed the gunman filed a complaint
against one of his flight instructors
here in Pensacola the New York Times
reports in the days before the Pensacola
attack the gunman traveled to New York
City but there's nothing to indicate he
was planning some kind of attack in New
York City he purchased his weapon
legally according to the FBI and now
Florida's governor is saying because of
that there should have been better
vetting to stop a man like this from
arming himself I'm a big supporter of
the Second Amendment but the Second
Amendment applies so that we the
American people can keep in bear arms it
does not apply to Saudi Arabians Florida
Governor Ron de Santos appeared
disgusted by Friday's mass shooting the
gunman muhammad saeed al sham Rami used
a Glock 9-millimeter handgun to execute
the three sailors including Mohammed
Haytham who chose to follow in his
mother Evelyn Brady's footsteps and
became a sailor I am so very proud of
everything you have accomplished and I
miss you I will miss you dearly
Ryan Blackwell was among eight others
wounded in the attack two some rounds
six people in the process and
and still trying to piece everything
together the 21 year old shooter was a
second lieutenant in the Royal Saudi Air
Force The Associated Press's reported
that the gunman held a dinner party days
earlier where he watched mass shooting
videos with three other Saudi students
according to the AP one of the three
students who attended the dinner party
recorded video outside the classroom
building as the shooting was taking
place as much as I would love to answer
any questions about the videos or any
other presumption information that's out
there my goal is not to continue the
misinformation campaign did somebody
record the shooting as it happened
there's a lot of review that still needs
to go on as to what happened that day if
it's misinformation please clear it up
for us
the FBI later told us there were
multiple videos from base security
surveillance as well as witness cell
phone videos taken outside the building
during and after the shooting our
investigation has not led us to any
information that indicates that there is
any credible threat to our community
there was no credible threat Friday
morning and three sailors are dead and
so now almost three days later you're
telling me there's no credible threat so
there's nothing changed between Friday
and today that's Escambia County Sheriff
David Morgan whose deputies responded to
the scene and killed the shooter I get
to sense that you and the FBI are not
quite seeing eye-to-eye we're not
singing the same song yet we've not sat
down with the bureau and got a briefing
that we know are elements that affect
our community the base is still closed
to the public what you see behind me are
cars that are essential personnel
heading into work look the FBI says they
still don't know whether the gunmen
acted alone or whether he was part of a
larger network the other Saudi nationals
who are training here learning how to
fly are all accounted for and we're told
their boss their Saudi commander is
restricting them to the base while the
investigation is ongoing David thank you
we see they're pushing for answers so
many questions remain I think about
those three families those three sailors
David breaking off for us thank you very
much